la classe pupitre est une classe pour
les bâtards elle est constituée d'un
couteau comme celui ci était face aux
drones mais face aux ennemis le total
aille au [ __ ] c'est vraiment pas
pratique d'être invincible tous les
jours trucage de l'extrême l'homme qui
pousse la chaise et surtout des
compétences athlétiques hors norme une
endurance in et je pourrais arrêter avec
cette chanson de mère bordel une vitesse
très très rapide grâce à un poids très
léger
[Musique]
bref la classe [ __ ] c'est une classe
pour les mégots rufisque with you le
monde sait squeeze on se retrouve
aujourd'hui sur black ops deux pour
jouer avec l'athlète qui put alors
[ __ ] ça chauffe la barque
malheureusement on est en pleine partie
parce que j'avais fait une super à
trouver ton machin et à mon plus grand
ma plus grande déception la carte
mémoire de la caméra café est donc bon
c'est pas grave on se rattrape alors
faute d'efficacité que je tue comme of
bon ok alors j'ai des futurs combats gg
euros sûrement les effets d'avoir écouté
du one direction
je suis un gros troll non honnêtement
j'ai rien contre mais c'est juste drôle
de de faire les mecs itunes france est
marrant puis après de voir les groupies
du groupe faire c'est qu'il est trop
beau un bref sans rien alors c'est parti
c'est ça la classe pupitre est une plaie
suturée invisible tu cours très très
vite pour tuer plein d'ennemis lacroix
qui passaient par là ont fait le tour
bon on a pas eu d
erp là monsieur y en avoir d'autres
voilà double file alors vous allez voir
c'est plutôt efficace en démolition ou
même si la map là elle va pas être à mon
avantage je pense dans le sens où elle
est plutôt espacées vous voyez des
grands couloirs comme ça c'est pas trop
tôt pour jouer avec ça mais écoutez on
va essayer de faire ce qu'on peut alors
attendez juste poussé shops amgen bordel
[ __ ] si j'avais sur un jour que je
ferai une vidéo avec des cheveux roses
défendre et on va aller salut ça va
bonjour bref alors on a essayé de la
jouer tactique on va pas prendre
d'armand j'ai dit que je jouais qu'à la
cause
or merde je savais toujours ceux qui ont
moins d'hésitation genre est ce que
c'est un allié non sera d'aller à merde
sans aimer les chiens
voilà on va passer de [ __ ] par contre
excusez moi mais les gens je suis j'ai
trop du mal à parler en même temps alors
là on a juste l'apparemment on va
laisser de la baratte au maroc
non non montre toi sale est un un 1080
coups de couteau c'était magnifique
genre tronçon à côté de son vomi
compteront double symbole qu'est ce tu
fais là on continue je crois car n'est
plus craind moi je passe par là allez
allez
hélas si on defuse senio l'état sauvage
avec violeta des hammams saunas bambara
pour que ce soir et voilà alors là c'est
pas beau ça on fait genre on n'a pas vu
ce genre les abus non en fait nous coûte
ifo vachement jouer enfin vous allez
voir ou pousser des plantes où j'aime
les plantes font franchement joué en mai
que j'étais trop bizarre dans la vidéo
où j'aime j'aime les vases barrière
cassée
non sans rien mais il faut vraiment
faire le mec qui fait des feintes et
tout comme ça d' ennemi il est
complètement du père et
il arrive tout droit du coup j'ai même
débloqué un drone qui me plaît elle va
croire je passe à droite à gauche du bus
et non halal et bata ils ont fait un
deux ou là mon casque et s'évade faisais
mon casque n'est pas content tu as ils
ont fait une technique l'aop séparation
de bim boom alors le truc chiant avec la
classe pupitre sais que tu as une
tomahawk épanouir au nahd
alors je vous l'avez vous avez vu obata
et même une vieille femme les mecs
qu'est ce que mes amis font pas sûr à
temps pour quoi ils sont pas sur un
bordel je sais pas vous voyez regarder
si on n'a que non mais ça c'est un truc
qui me ta gueule toi
[ __ ] à pâques c'est vraiment chaud sur
cette map bordel puisque on accède à un
long couloir alors est-ce qu'on pourrait
défier vous savez quoi de manière bon
avec mon couteau je pourrais pas trop d
fusent de toute manière on va essayer de
faire le tour et tuer les ennemis les
empêcher d'arriver sur l'objectif
pendant que ma team defuse salue au nom
mais ça par contre le couteau de black
up c'est vraiment une belle blouse 1 je
tiens à préciser
c'est ces gens le couteau en plastique
que tu achètes à ton gosse quand et
comme les petits dans sa réponse c'est
naze quoi tu fais ça des fois ça marche
pas alors l'exemple parfait ou pas
comment ça se passe on est d'accord ou
pas il ya un mec qui arrive là-bas
[ __ ] et vite conduit voilà olalalala
[ __ ] ça va trop vite
oh c'est incroyable je veux tu étais
avec une trop grande sensibilité je sais
pas je com du 7 11 aussi un chai merde
je m'en fous je crois que faisait un
score meilleur que ça
excusez moi un jour là ma mèche je sais
maintenant l'effet que ça fait de
remettre sa mèche toutes les deux
minutes
suite non c'est juste qu'on a les
cultures de suite d'accord alors rien
mais qui jouable à côte gucci
aux remises au ralenti tout de suite
[Musique]
homage à pilton merde c'était juste
épique roya du monde d'ici là bas [ __ ]
la vache non non non ouais maintenant on
va faire le tour comme ça elle était
trop belle
elle était trop belle quoi la claque une
actrice pornographique
attention il va arriver gbagbo sont là
ils sont là ils soient annoncés tendance
toi voilà passe au dessus on va le nay
qu'il n'y en pas king bed bath and am on
s'en sort pas trop mal ou une classe
comme ça sans dec s'arrête à temps on va
peut-être même gagner la manche
ça serait quand même assez incroyable
talent joue jamais en démolition
pourtant c'est un très bon mode de jeu
où il faut bien jouer objectif j'adore
ce mode
j'aurais pu aussi jouer au merde merde
au nom aller vite vite vite et faisait
des choses des choses des choses
allaient mezine mm cover ça fera jamais
mes amis sont trop loin oui oui oui
comme enjeu bien là on est rose [ __ ] et
trois enfants ont trouvé ou mère j'avais
vraiment une tomahawks depuis quand la
vache c'est quoi
c'est trop une pub
alala les lives on essaie moment ils
vont tous venir là puisqu'il reste que
35 secondes
je stresse pour la match assez bon voilà
ça y va à la parole à tous que tu
pourtant on en a tous je crois qu'il
nous empêche de se prendre des parts à
et/ou monde et qu'on a six secondes on
peut y aller là on va juste essayer de
ne pas se prendre au regard des virées
plutôt matin non tu peux pas tester mon
style en classe pupitre mec c'est bon on
y va allez on s'en bat les couilles 1
c'est la fête vous me donner un gage
dans les commentaires si je fais un
ratio positif en passant je sais pas si
j'ai ratio positif mais c'est à la fin
de cette vidéo j'en ai un fonds de
donner un gage pour le moment il est
positif pour le moment alors je vais
peut-être un gage bon suivez moi sur
twitter vous me donnerez le gage dans
les commentaires et je suis par exemple
je sais une photo ja publié sur twitter
allez hop c'est parti ben hammam vous
mes journées sont longues gagne ou on
gagne avec la classe pupitre je fais ça
le truc qui ce mardi avec quoi c'est
parti on continue la classe tu put aller
au top c'est le cas je voulais être
tellement drôle non c'est vraiment un
truc de nous parce que c'est comme les
renards dans le w2 les mains sûres que
dans mw2 il ya quand même le nom mais ce
serait trop bien mais c'est au début
vous savez on fait un footing beau match
alors est-ce qu'on peut regarder
ouais non
bob et même personne mais pourquoi il me
suit lutins tu veux pas jouer mec
regardez le gavage et roger avec lui tu
fais quoi toi tu sprint mais c'est pas
la faute qu'il tient très deux fois cinq
ignore fait alors est-ce que made in
fine jack
vous avez vu ça s auj c'est un peu pic
ouais c'est ça ta yves boisset de punky
[ __ ] ma team souple et bougez vous qu
il a amorcé vin comme fer je crois qu'on
va pas vu c'est bon on continue à les
cours au chip elle est vrai ça très bien
pourquoi
[ __ ] mais des fois je comprends pas
délire quand ça arrive je peux rien
faire la main mais trop grande c'est
horrible temps que j'arrive ils ont tant
de m'ajuster cent mille fois on va
essayer de passer par là la fenêtre à la
personne là alors semblé qu on y va on y
vend débat droite gauche est un mec qui
a tenté de me tirer dessus il va arriver
logiquement non c'est bon bon
en plus il est trop naze quoi le mec
j'ai tant de courir 20 mètres qui met
ces [ __ ] ah oui c'est bien les gars
disent il restait sur âge arrive je vais
être une très très grande utilité
c'est une aide notamment d'un mec mais
il faut quoi dans le pot mon gars
olalala mais c'est pas possible de faire
des choses comme ça ça devrait être puni
par la loi quoi deux ans
d'emprisonnement brûlée vive tendue
tiens si je te covert enfin je fais le
napa amorce perfect perfect maï pelem
c'est quoi on va les attendre qu'il y
avait un mec là va y avoir un mec qui
ont été activés coucou
heureusement guy l'état car c'est moi je
sais pas ce que j'aurais fait un coucou
alors que les stratégies
il ya du monde là-bas alors attendez ce
qu'ils sachent tellement concentré
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire le tour par
là pour aller en bas à gauche je me le
demande je veux mais tu m'as pas les
seuls à prendre des cover by les mecs
allez moi je vais essayer d'aller amorcé
à pendant ce temps là comme ça ils
seront paniqués sont plus quoi faire
allez ça peut être là pourquoi tu
amorces pas mec [ __ ] le mec il a à
côté ils avancent pas quoi thein sein
des fois je les comprends pas les gens
shit
j'aime ouvertes les gens j'oblige et en
plus ça n'aura servi à rien voilà tout
ce qu'il ya sur les gars ça va être la
guerre là faudrait les prendre en bac ha
long feuilleton va la gauche
go go go gauche gauche la gauche je
courais les cheveux roses dans l'air
[Musique]
[ __ ] c'est une blague mais c'est pas
auprès les tuer au couteau
[ __ ] merde mais j'ai trop le sable
mais c'est n'importe quoi la tourelle
qui qui qui cite au lavage légalement
ils ont mille trucs magnéto oh [ __ ]
ils jouent bien en phase 1 ils jouent
bien faut faire le tour voici sadaoui ce
que je te suis je fais comme toi et tous
gemecs pourquoi c'est une fenêtre c'est
quoi ton [ __ ] voilà le campeur je suis
désolé sadaoui ce qui est alors on va
essayer juste d'avancer en mode classe
pas put n'était pas trop mal aujourd'hui
mon est tué par exemple on avait un
autre je crois ouais elle est là tu fais
quoi boulet au
alors là un mac à bien jouer la classe
pupute fort qui me l'a bien vu dans les
faits cela coûtera la vache ça j'aurais
dû garder ma tomahawk la jeune femme
quelle incroyable que voulez-vous faire
messieurs dames alla il y en a qui
arrivent dans le bail qui en a 4 2
devant ça sent bon pour nous il aura su
minutes 50 bon tout est jouable
voilà la vache de temps qui m'a lancé
sept homologues de merde à une font rage
et un bond à 18,25 le gage ce sera pour
une autre fois les genres
je suis désolé un [ __ ] par contre la
vidéo va peut-être coupé g plus beaucoup
de batteries dans le canon la séquence
était comme moi je vais tenir au second
tour on se connaissait pas mais ah bah
non mais je pose il est immense a c'est
vraiment pas la map qu'il faut un holà
la vache tu veux te tenir au spawn
attend gentil en premier [ __ ] marché
qu'un dingue comme les racines mais
merde
oh lalala lalala mon dieu bon les gens
j'en ai marre épique rage
je prends le bas cité cathare je n'ai vu
là c'est une blague mec c'est une blague
mec c est bien là bien tu fais quoi
j'vous des halles à la légende je vous
dis direct on va se déchaîner un coût
puisque j'en peux plus jouer
voilà
non mais j'utilise au quotidien
allez hop on dégage merci au revoir bon
on fait on m'a fait déjà plus de kiel en
10 secondes avec le pacificateur tu avec
la classe [ __ ] en tout une partie
je pense que ça veut tout dire la classe
pépite hépatites but que ça non
honnêtement c'est une classe vraiment
bien dans les genres dans les eaux
stagnent à la truck dans les petites
maps genre c'est là où il ya le bateau
et tout s'est vraiment bien
voilà la magie fait bien trop mal allez
les gars à go go go
bon ok on va partir sur une troisième
manche je sais pas si grave mais je sais
pas si je la fais en classe [ __ ]
j'aimerais bien juste gagner quoi ah
[ __ ] pas de chance ça c'est le truc
vraiment pas toutes ces tueries tu
arrives dans un homme qui regarde à
droite et mac et à gauche quand gerba de
l'ocs
allez bon ah non c'est non on fait un
petit kit pour la focale
ouais aller de kippour la fin ouais bon
double attend qu'ils te calmes quoi au
10 ou alors c'est bon les mecs les mecs
ont cover on cover je sais que ça va
arriver dans le bail parce qu'ils sont
très malins oh les mecs ont cover ont
couvert comme des boeufs on causera que
là que peu la queue port mais que cochon
la queue poulets canards à la la la la
la c'est beau non là ce qu'on fait on va
mettre un drone ça nous aide à savoir
par la rive ouest très bonne au sein
très très très bruno merde t'as vite
continuer les mecs les mecs le mec cover
commerciaux
le mec qui bannit cola cola à woippy
tawhidi ah oui au plus tard le mec qui
se pointent kilo newton ans pas courant
mais c'est pas con expliquent ils pour
nous tenir à nos spawn plutôt que
d'aller cover les mecs
regardez bien si la personne ses
objectifs ça va péter ça danse oui sous
want et oui on a fait le ratio positif
on a pas qu'apple ratio positif à cause
de la classe puis de [ __ ] et la camsa
était à tous deux matches à rallonge
pour faire regarder cette quelques armes
naga ou la place plus de [ __ ] est dans
les bacs on a tout niké châteaulin
poteau pour nouvelle vidéo passez voir
la vidéo c'est à dire sur les pavés je
te montre que chaouki par l'amitié de
toi tu vas de résistance
[Musique]
bon maintenant mammalogie vaincu la page
prochaine à toi la toile apostolska de
son histoire
oh